>> IN RUSSIA, A SIGN THAT
FRUSTRATION WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN
AND HIS UNPROVOKED INVASION IS
GROWING.
DEPUTIES FROM 18 MUNICIPAL
DISTRICTS IN MOSCOW AND ST.
PETERSBURG HAVE SIGNED A
PETITION DEMANDING PUTIN'S
RESIGNATION, CALLING HIS ACTIONS
DETRIMENTAL TO RUSSIAN AND ITS
FUTURE.
FREDPL PLEITGEN JOINS US FROM
BERLIN.
IT SEEMS LIKE A SERIOUS AND RARE
REBUKE FROM OFFICIALS?
>> I WOULD SAY IT IS VERY RARE
AND SOMETHING THAT IS NOTEWORTHY
AS WELL, ESPECIALLY IF YOU LOOK
AT THE STATE OF THE OPPOSITION
IN RUSSIA RIGHT NOW WHERE MANY
OPPOSITION OFFICIALS ARE IN
JAIL, HAVE BEEN SIDELINED OR
HAVE BEEN EXILED.
ALSO, OF COURSE, THE STATE OF
THE RUSSIAN FREE MEDIA AS WELL
IS ONE THAT IS ALSO DIRE.
SO JUST IN THAT LIGHT, THIS IS
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT IS
DEFINITELY NOTEWORTHY.
ONE THING WE HAVE TO KEEP IN
MIND, THESE ARE LOCAL OFFICIALS,
FAIRLY LOW LEVEL OFFICIALS, AND
THERE'S MOTMANY WHO HAVE SIGNED
THIS PETITION, BUT THE FACT THIS
IS BEING DONE PUBLICLY AT ALL IS
SOMETHING THAT IS DEFINITELY
NOTEWORTHY.
IF YOU SPEAK TO SOME OF THE
FOLKS, RUSSIAN OFFICIALS, IF YOU
SPEAK ALSO TO SOME OF THE PEOPLE
IN KREMLIN CONTROLLED MEDIA, YOU
DO REALLY GET A SENSE THERE IS A
VERY MUTED, VERY DIFFICULT
FEELING THERE RIGHT NOW AS THIS
UKRAINIAN COUNTEROFFENSIVE ROLLS
ON.
WHAT THE RUSSIANS HAVE BEEN
SAYING IS THEY HAVE BEEN CALLING
THIS A REORGANIZATION OF RUSSIAN
FORCES, BUT YOU DO HEAR SOME
PRETTY CRITICAL VOICES ALSO,
ESPECIALLY AMONG PEOPLE WHO HAVE
VERY CLOSE TO VLADIMIR PUTIN AND
WHO HAVE BEEN SUPPORTING
RUSSIA'S AMIVATION OF UKRAINE AS
WELL.
YOU LOOK AT A CHECHEN STRONGMAN,
HE CAME OUT AND WAS ANGRY,
SAYING MISTAKES HAD BEEN MADE.
IF THINGS DON'T CHANGE, HE WOULD
TAKE IT UP WITH TOP LEADERSHIP
OF RUSSIA, MEANING VLADIMIR
PUTIN HIMSELF.
YOU GET A SENSE RUSSIA IS
HURTING.
THEY REALIZE IT'S DIFFICULT
TIMES THEY'RE ON RIGHT NOW, AND
RIGHT NOW YOU CAN TELL THAT THEY
SEE THAT THE OPERATION THAT
THEY'RE DOING IN UKRAINE IS
DEFINITELY IN A LOT OF TROUBLE
AT THE MOMENT.
>> ALTHOUGH IT SEEMS THAT THE
RUSSIAN PRESIDENT IS IN DENIAL.
AT LEAST WHAT HE'S VOCALIZING TO
HIS PEOPLE THERE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT REPORTING.
LET'S BRING IN CEDRIC LEIGHTON,
CNN MILITARY ANALYST.
COLONEL, UKRAINE HAS NOW
CAPTURED, RECAPTURED, I SHOULD
SAY, MORE THAN 1,000 SQUARE
MILES.
AND I WANT TO POINT OUT ON THE
MAP IT'S KIND OF IN THE EASTERN
REGION AROUND KHARKIV.
WE ALSO KNOW KHERSON HAS HAD
SOME FIGHTING AND SOME GAINS BY
UKRAINIANS AS WELL.
WHAT HAS CHANGED?
WHY IS THIS COUNTEROFFENSIVE SO
SUCCESSFUL?
>> WELL, THIS IS A HUGE DEAL,
AND THE REASON THIS
COUNTEROFFENSIVE IS SO
SUCCESSFUL IS BECAUSE THE
UKRAINIANS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF SEVERAL
THINGS.
ONE OF THEM IS THE WEAPONS THAT
THEY HAVE GOTTEN FROM THE WEST.
THE U.S. AND OTHER NATIONS,
ESPECIALLY NATOINA NATIONS, HAV
BEANE TO DEPLOY WEAPONS QUICKLY
AND THEY HAVE USED THEM IN THIS
AREA RIGHT HERE, THE KHARKIV
REGION, THIS IS THE AREA WHERE A
LOT OF THAT HAS HAPPENED.
THEY HAVE ALSO USED SOME OF THEM
DOWN SOUTH, BUT THE KEY THING TO
NOTE ABOUT THESE AREAS IS THIS
IS REALLY PROTECTING UKRAINE'S
SECOND LARGEST CITY.
AND THE MORE THAT THE UKRAINIANS
CAN MOVE FORWARD IN THIS
DIRECTION AND PUSH THE RUSSIANS
OUT, THE MORE LIKELY THE
UKRAINIANS ARE TO KEEP THIS
TERRITORY AND THE LESS LIKELY IT
IS FOR THE RUSSIANS TO ACTUALLY
RETAKE THE TERRITORY.
>> STRATEGICALLY, HOW IMPORTANT
OR CRUCIAL IS THIS SPECIFIC
REGION?
>> SO IT IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THIS, THIS
AREA RIGHT HERE, SO EVERYTHING
IN UKRAINE IS BASICALLY DIVIDED
BY THIS RIVER, THE DNIPRO RIVER.
EVERYTHING TO THE EAST IS MUCH
EASIER FOR RUSSIA TO GAIN AHOLD
OF BECAUSE WHEN THEY FIRST
STARTED THIS, THEY WERE
BASICALLY MOVING LIKE THIS.
THEY WERE MOVING INTO UKRAINE
FROM RUSSIA.
BUT THEY WERE UNABLE TO
PROSECUTE THEIR ADVANTAGE THIS
WAY, AND WHAT THIS MEANS IS THIS
AREA RIGHT HERE, THE AREA AROUND
KHARKIV AND THEN THIS AREA DOWN
IN THROUGH THE EASTERN PART,
THIS AREA IS SO IMPORTANT FROM A
RESOURCES STANDPOINT, FROM AN
INDUSTRIAL STANDPOINT, AND IT'S
IN ESSENCE WITH THE XEPG OF THE
AGRICULTURE REGIONS, THE MOST
IMPORTANT PART OF UKRAINE FROM
AN ECONOMIC STANDPOINT.
>> I REMEMBER EARLIER WHEN THIS
INVASION BEGAN, WE TALKED ABOUT
HOW UKRAINE MIGHT HAVE A
FIGHTING SPIRIT IN A MUCH
GREATER AMOUNT THAN RUSSIA BUT
RUSSIA HAD THE NUMBERS.
HOWEVER, THAT SEEMS TO HAVE
FLIPPED.
RUSSIA SAYS UKRAINIAN FORCES
OUTNUMBER THEM BY EIGHT TIMES,
ALTHOUGH I DON'T THINK RUSSIA
HAS THE SAME FIGHTING SPIRIT.
I'M JUST TALKING ABOUT THE
NUMBERS.
ARE YOU CONFIDENT UKRAINE WILL
BE ABLE TO HOLD ON TO THIS
TERRITORY THEY REGAINED?
>> I THINK THEY CAN DO IT.
OF COURSE, THERE ARE LOT OF
THINGS THAT HAVE TO HAPPEN.
LET'S LOOK AUTOTHE NORTHEAST IN
DETAIL.
WHAT YOU HAVE IS THE AREA AROUND
KHARKIV, RIGHT OVER HERE, AND
THEN YOU HAVE WHERE MELISSA WAS,
WHICH IS RIGHT HERE, RIGHT ON
THE LINE BETWEEN RIGHT NOW
BETWEEN RUSSIAN AND UKRAINIAN
FORCES.
THE UKRAINIANS WERE ABLE TO MOVE
IN THIS DIRECTION.
THIS IS THE RUSSIAN BORDER RIGHT
HERE.
THE UKRAINIANS CAN KEEP THIS IF
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO GET THE
WEAPONS FROM THE WEST AND IF THE
RUSSIANS CONTINUE TO HAVE SUPPLY
CHAIN FAILURES.
IF THAT CONTINUES TO HAPPEN,
THEN I'M REASONABLY CONFIDENT
THE UKRAINIANS CAN KEEP THIS
AREA.
>> OKAY, COLONEL CEDRIC
LEIGHTON, GOOD TO GET THIS
UPDATE.
THANK YOU FOR OFFERING YOUR
EXPERTISE AND YOUR INSIGHTS.